>> Sandra: PRESIDENT BIDEN
UNVEILING HIS PLAN TO COMBAT
RACIAL INJUSTICE, ON THE 100TH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE TULSA RACE
MASSACRE, A HORRIFIC EVENT THAT
LEFT MORE THAN 300 PEOPLE DEAD.
PROMISING TO SPEND BILLIONS ON
RACIAL EQUITY AND ASKING
AMERICANS TO ROOT OUT SYSTEMIC
RACISM.
--
>> AND THEY WEREN'T EVEN
EMBARRASSED BY IT.
THEY WERE PROUD OF IT.
AND THAT HATE BECAME EMBEDDED
SYSTEMATICALLY AND SYSTEMICALLY
IN OUR LAWS AND OUR CULTURE.
WE DO OURSELVES NO FAVORS BY
PRETENDING NONE OF THIS EVER
HAPPENED.
OR DOES NOT IMPACT US TODAY,
BECAUSE IT DOES STILL IMPACT US
TODAY.
>> Sandra: TOOK CLOSE THE RACE
WEALTH GAP, THE SPENDING MONEY,
THE MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF MONEY
THAT HE IS TALKING ABOUT HERE
AND OTHER PLACES, WILL THAT FIX
THE PROBLEM?
>> Harlod: IT IS PART OF
HELPING TO FIX THE PROBLEM,
SOMETHING THAT WE TALK ABOUT
RACIAL INEQUITY IS A SENSE THAT
WE ARE SAYING THE COUNTRY IS BAD
OR WE ARE SAYING THAT WHITE
PEOPLE ARE BAD OR WE ARE
DEGRADING PEOPLE, WHEN YOU CAN
LOOK AT IT NARROWLY LIKE THAT,
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT IT IS REALLY
ABOUT.
YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED IN
GREENWOOD, WE WERE HAVING AN
INTERESTING CONVERSATION ABOUT
THIS BEFORE GOING ON, BURN DOWN
FOR THE SUCCESSFUL BLACK
COMMUNITY, ECONOMICAL, SO TAKING
EFFORTS AND TARGETING THE MONEY
AND SAYING, WE AS AMERICA NO
OTHER COUNTRY ON THE FACE OF THE
EARTH THEY CAN GO THROUGH THIS
AND RECOVER AND THRIVE THE WAY
THAT WE HAVE THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE HAVE, SO IF IT MAKES US
A LITTLE UNSETTLED AND
UNCOMFORTABLE HAVING THE
CONVERSATION SO BE IT AS LONG AS
IT DOES NOT COME FROM A PLACE OF
MALICE, BUT TRYING TO MAKE
THINGS BETTER.
I GAVE HIM THE BENEFIT OF THE
DOUBT TO DO THIS.
IF THEY NEED TO SHIFT AND
REORGANIZE AND REDO IT, AT THE
START I THINK THAT YOU GIVE THEM
THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
>> Sandra: AFTER THAT
INTERESTING CONVERSATION YOU HAD
WITH HAROLD, I'M THE FIRST
PRESIDENT IN 100 YEARS TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE TRUTH OF WHAT
TOOK PLACE THERE AT TULSA.
>> Greg: THIS WAS NOT TAUGHT
TO ME IN HIGH SCHOOL OR COLLEGE,
AND I WAS THINKING, BECAUSE I AM
ON THE WEST COAST?
BUT IT IS A HORRIBLE STORY, I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO TALK
ABOUT, BUT THAT IS A SEPARATE
ISSUE THAN FROM THIS IDEA OF
EQUITY.
I'M GOING TO BE AN APOSTLE OF
THOMAS SOWELL, SO WHEN THEY
SHIFTED FROM EQUALITY TO EQUITY
IT BECOMES A DIFFERENT STORY.
EVERYBODY WANTS EQUALITY OF
OPPORTUNITY, BUT WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THE EQUALITY OF OUTCOME IS
IMPOSSIBLE, AND IT IS HARMFUL.
THERE ARE CERTAIN PLACES WHERE
THE PERCENTAGE OF 5.5 WHITE GUYS
WITH AN OSCAR BACKGROUND WILL
NOT BE IN THE NBA.
LESS THAN 0.0%.
SO WE HAVE TO ASK OURSELVES, WHY
ARE WE SHIFTING FROM EQUALITY TO
EQUITY, AND IT IS BECAUSE WE
REALIZE THAT DISCRIMINATION,
DELIBERATE DISCRIMINATION IS
ILLEGAL.
AND WE KNOW IT IS NOT HAPPENING.
EVERYBODY IN CORPORATIONS WANTS
TO HIRE MINORITIES.
COLLEGES WANT MINORITIES, SO
WHERE'S THE DISCRIMINATION?
IT'S BEFORE THAT.
IT HAS TO BE BEFORE THAT,
BECAUSE WE DO SEE PROBLEMS ON
THE STREET AND LOTS OF ISSUES,
SO IT HAPPENS -- WE ARE MEETING
THIS PROBLEM TO ELATE.
AND THAT'S WHY I GO BACK TO
THOMAS SOWELL, HE WILL BRING UP
THREE AREAS, WHAT ARE THE THREE
AREAS THAT NEGATIVELY IMPACTED
BLACK LIVES?
HE WILL SAY THAT THE WELFARE
SYSTEM DESTROYED THE FAMILIES.
TEACHER UNIONS KILLED
COMPETITION, SCHOOL CHOICE KILLS
EDUCATION.
OF THE THIRD THING WOULD BE THE
DE-ESCALATION OR DEFUNDING OF
POLICE WHICH MAKES COMMUNITIES
WHERE MINORITIES LIVE UNSAFE.
SO GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRACY BY
LIBERALS HAS HURT FAMILIES,
SCHOOLS, AND COMMUNITIES.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES EVERYBODY
SUSPICIOUS.
WHAT CAN THEY DO THAT CAN MAKE
IT WORSE?
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT, I GUESS.
>> Jesse: IF I WERE A
BLACK AMERICAN, YOU KNOW THAT I
HAVE MY DNA TEST.
.1%.
AND IF I SEE ANOTHER WHITE
LIBERAL LIKE JOE BIDEN COMING
AROUND AND SAYING HOW THEY ARE
GOING TO HELP ME, I WOULD SHAKE
MY HEAD.
I MEAN, FOR HOW MANY YEARS HAVE
WHITE LIBERALS SAID THAT THEY
ARE GOING TO HELP BLACK AMERICA,
AND YOU STILL HAVE BLACK POVERTY
RATES, BLACK UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
TWICE WHAT WHITE UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE IS.
OF THE BLACK EDUCATION GAP HAS
GOTTEN BIGGER.
LESS BLACK FAMILY IS IN TACT.
IS ANY OF THAT WORKING?
WHAT WE ARE DOING?
I'M ACTUALLY THINKING NOW AND
THE GOVERNMENT SAYS THAT THEY
WANT TO HELP BLACKS THEY ARE
ACTUALLY HURTING BLACKS, BECAUSE
WHERE ARE THE TRILLIONS THAT WE
HAVE ALREADY SPENT GO, JOE?
JUST THE RACE HUSTLERS THAT RUN
THE FEDERAL PROGRAMS THAT DON'T
WORK?
BECAUSE THEY DID NOT GO TO THE
PEOPLE THAT NEEDED THE HELP, SO
IF SOMEBODY IS SAYING I'M GOING
TO HELP YOU, I'M GOING TO SAY,
I'M GOING TO HELP MYSELF AND
OPERATE MY SCHOOLS IN MY
BUSINESSES AND MY FAMILY AND
KEEP MORE OF MY MONEY AND I BET
BLACK AMERICANS WOULD THRIVE IF
WHITE LIBERALS STOP TRYING TO
HELP THEM.
>> Greg: IF THEY LET THE
EDUCATION FLOURISH THAT WOULD BE
A BIG START.
>> Jesse: AND THEY WANT TO
CALL BLACK AMERICANS --
WHEN THEY ARE LABELED VICTIMS IT
MEANS THEY NEED HELP FROM WHITE
LIBERALS AND HELP MEANS VOTES
COMING TO GET VOTES IN EXCHANGE
FOR HELP, ONCE THEY ARE NOT
VICTIMS ANYMORE, THEY DON'T NEED
HELP AND THEN THEY DON'T GET THE
VOTES COME E-CIG YOU SEE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND I KNOW THAT
YOU AGREE, BECAUSE YOU ARE
SHAKING YOUR HEAD YES, THEY KEEP
PLAYING THE RACE CARD BECAUSE IT
IS VICTIMIZING BLACK AMERICA AND
KEEPS THE DEMOCRATS AND POWER.
AND THAT WILL NEVER CHANGE.
>> Harlod: WHAT IF I TOLD YOU
FROM 1920 TO 1980, 99% OF ALL
LOANS FOR HOMES, RESIDENTIAL
MORTGAGES WERE ONLY PROVIDED TO
WHITE AMERICANS AND 99.5 PERCENT
OF THOSE PROVIDING IT WHERE THE
GOVERNMENT?
WHAT IF I TOLD YOU THE NUMBER
ONE CREATIVE WEALTH IN ANY
FAMILY REGARDLESS OF WHAT YOU
LOOK LIKE IN THE COUNTRY IS IN
YOUR HOME, IF YOU DENY THE
NUMBERS FOR WHAT THEY ARE AND I
THINK THAT THERE WAS AN
INTENTIONAL EFFORT, PART OF WHAT
HE IS TRYING TO DO AND I DON'T
DISPUTE A LOT OF THE THINGS YOU
SAY ABOUT LIBERALS SAYING THEY
WANT TO SOLVE EVERY PROBLEM, I
GET A LITTLE CONCERNED WITH THAT
SPACE.
BUT I THINK FINANCE, ECONOMICS,
WE HAVE TO FIND WAYS TO TELL
THESE STORIES TO REMIND PEOPLE
OF WHAT HAPPENED AND TWO, OF
THOSE THREE THINGS, THERE WERE
CHALLENGES BEFORE, WE WERE
TRYING TO ADDRESS THEM AND THE
ANSWERS WERE INSUFFICIENT.
THAT DOES NOT MEAN THAT WE STOP
TRYING.
WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO OFFER
IDEAS AFTER IDEA OF WHETHER IT
IS CONSERVATIVE OR LIBERAL TO
SOLVE IT.
I BELIEVE 1920-1985% OF THAT
MONEY HAD GONE TO BLACK
HOMEOWNERS, HOW MANY MORE BLACK
HOMEOWNERS, BECAUSE THE NUMBER
ONE DETERMINE IT FOR HOW WELL
YOU DO IN SCHOOL IS THE ZIP CODE
YOU COME FROM, REGARDLESS, SO IF
YOU ADD MORE MONEY AND LOCAL
COMMUNITY, MORE WOULD GO TO
SCHOOLS.
WE WON'T SOLVE IT IN A MINUTE
AND A HALF, BUT THERE IS A LOT
MORE TO IT THAN WHAT WE
DISCUSSED.
>> Dagen: ONE OF THE WORDS
THAT YOU WILL HEAR FROM BLACK
AMERICANS WHO WERE UPSET ABOUT
INEQUALITY IS OWNERSHIP, AND IT
GOES BACK TO THE TULSA MASSACRE,
IT GOES BACK TO HOME OWNERSHIP,
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS A WORD
THAT YOU WILL HEAR AND A MESSAGE
OFTEN.
IN TERMS OF LIBERALS, LOOK NO
FURTHER THAN THE LIBERAL MASS OF
SILICON VALLEY.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE PERCENTAGE OF
THEIR WORKFORCE THAT IS
REPRESENTED BY A BLACK
AMERICANS, IT IS DISMAL, IT IS
APPALLING IN TECHNICAL JOBS,
FACEBOOK HAS LESS THAN 2% OF
PEOPLE IN TECHNICAL JOBS WHO ARE
BLACK.
YOU MEAN TO TELL ME OVER THE
LAST 20 YEARS OR SO SINCE THESE
COMPANIES WERE FOUNDED, THEY
COULD NOT HAVE DONE SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT AND ACTUALLY GOING
INTO HIGH SCHOOL AND PULLING
PEOPLE AND EDUCATING THEM
THEMSELVES AS THEY ARE STARTING
TO DO THAT, IT'S A LITTLE TOO
LATE, IN TERMS OF WHAT JOE BIDEN
WANTS TO DO, AND MIGHT BE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
LAST WEEK THERE WERE TWO COURTS
THAT BLOCKED JOE BIDEN SMALL
BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION FROM
HANDING OUT BENEFITS BASED ON
RACE, IT IS $29 MILLION
RESTAURANT RELIEF FUND, DO YOU
KNOW WHO GETS TO THE FRONT OF
THE LINE?
IT IS MINORITIES AND WOMEN.
AT THE BACK OF THE LINE WITH
EVERYBODY ELSE, AND IF THAT
PROGRAM RUNS OUT OF MONEY BEFORE
IT GETS TO SOMEONE WHO IS A
WHITE MAN, THEN YOU ARE OUT OF
LUCK.
AND TO THOSE TWO JUDGES, TWO
COURTS HAVE BLOCKED THAT PROGRAM
SO FAR.
BECAUSE VICE AND DISCRIMINATION
IS WRONG AND CONFRONTATIONAL
REGARDLESS OF THE GROUP